we're very pleased to have with us today
Thomas Ferguson who will discuss with us
the 1988 election tom is a visiting
professor of political science at the
University of Massachusetts at Boston
and is a professor of government at the
University of Texas at Austin he's also
the co-author with Joel Rogers of
right-turn the decline of the Democrats
in the future of American politics for
the last several elections Tom has been
very closely focusing on the candidates
the economic interest behind them the
shifts and party alignment and the basic
developments of politics in the United
States so Tom we're very happy to have
you with us today to talk about the 1988
election this yesterday Michael Dukakis
named Lloyd Bentsen of Texas as his vice
president designate what does that
signify for you well my initial reaction
frankly is pretty much like Carter
glasses reaction when he Al Smith was
nominated on the Democratic ticket in
1928 I'm a Democrat still very still
that I have to confess that you know
you're once first look at this is to say
that in Benson well he's not an ogre and
it's a party at where there's you know
presumably going to be different points
of view you're not going to have a
political party sits from the extreme
right end of the party eye in the sky if
you look at his Senate voting record
over the last 10 or 15 years while it's
true as Dukakis said when I introduced
him that his civil rights record is
quite reasonable nevertheless he is
consistently among the most conservative
Democratic senators indeed one of my
colleagues has done some
multi-dimensional scaling maps of Senate
voting tells me the guy whom Benson most
strongly resembles most of the time is
Sam Nunn I remember back in the old days
seeing pictures of Benson though saying
by gosh we got to drop the bomb the
a-bomb yeah
on Korea and he also won the election
here by beating Ralph Yarborough for the
Democratic nomination for Senator you
can say that this is crystal yeah
McCarthy I dread mate on the other hand
one has to note that Benson for instance
if you look at his staff in Congress
this is a subtle point but it's true it
really reflects the political diversity
in the state you're not looking at a
staff for instance it's monolithically
conservative Benson particularly in the
last few years you know he tried to move
along various Democratic initiatives as
response to Reagan from 86 to 88 no he
for example did make some noise for
instance about the corporate minimum tax
and he's a look the guy is a
conservative Democrat on things like the
Contras I mean he's been an enthusiastic
backer of the Contras and unless you're
wild about war in Central America which
I'm not it's hard to see the point why
anyone would further that and you know
your caucus has said no Contras we're
wiping them out well we might want to
explore that a bit my judgment is that
both I'm hope this I believe it when I
see it that policy remains to be defined
but you may get a very good index of
this because it does appear that the
administration is going to come back
with another contra aid bill and
watching how Senator Benson and the
candidate Dukakis respond this I think
is a very good index of trying to find
out what will be the future yeah let's
look at why Benson was chosen the caucus
had several choices senator Benson is
after all the Niagara Falls of American
political finance I mean the party is
going to get very rich as a result of
this and there is no question that it's
been born in powerfully on me when I was
doing some studies of financing in a 76
campaign and that was a campaign in
which Benson they quickly stepped out
and sort of into the pool swam around
for a few laps and then got got right
back out of the pool I mean y'all I for
practice didn't go anywhere yeah but he
certainly raised an impressive pile of
cash and what's even more impressive
than just the the pile of it is where it
came from it came not only from Texas
but from the
work you're dealing and he has after all
been a major player and I chairman of
the Senate Finance Committee yeah this
is an absolutely central position in
American life and that sense you know he
is well known to a lot of well big
business interests in America he's known
for years he's known and trusted and
understood yeah
in other words more money more people
would contribute more money with Benson
in his vice president and say these
other guy I don't think there's any
quick the tip-off is probably when I
think Robert farmer who has been doing
the fundraising for Dukakis said he
wanted to raise more than forty million
in soft money this year soft money is
money that's outside the Federal
Election Commission a regulatory process
it should go or into the possibly he
meant into the DNC all the soft money is
not Democratic National Committee all
the soft money is not formally usually
counted into that at any rate everybody
scoff Fortune magazine just said a
couple weeks ago that that was probably
unrealistic they're going to make it
easy now they have done some systematic
campaign finance surveys pretty much
along the lines of the statistical
appendix that we present in a right turn
in 1984 the Democrats gets smashed and
they got wiped out now what's different
about 1988 and in what way did how did
you get from 84 to 88 and what you could
do that you know by tracing issues by
tracing events around gate and things
like that but if you look at it in sort
of corporate terms what you see is this
in 84 as we said in right turn and I
think demonstrated in the appendix is
that the Democrats get an overwhelming
percentage of there are sort of big
business cash out of the top of the
pyramid not total money but out of sort
of the major actors in IBM big fortune
500 companies yeah without saying those
are all Democratic kind that's the kind
of company I'm talking about these were
playing both sides no I mean though they
just pursue this the they got a huge
amount of money from investment bankers
and real estate the investment banking
money was very clearly directed toward
the deficit I mean they said this it
makes perfect sense at least on many
economic theories they're known to hold
so let's assume it's true since they
were saying and
then the real-estate people were running
were contributing these were largely
Northeast and Midwest with San Francisco
and some Atlanta thrown in these were
real estate magnets who were put simply
their buildings dependent on large-scale
funding from the government of urban aid
that urban aid contributes what it
competes one-for-one with the defense
budget and so these guys were
necessarily anti defense what would they
get in real estate well the mass transit
put simply as somebody said to me very
elegantly the is just a plain fact if
you build a large building in New York
it isn't going to pay off unless you've
got mass transit you simply can't bring
enough people in unless you're planning
to bring them and sort of stacked on top
of each other plus urban development the
urban development grants are you DAGs
which have just disappeared are nearly
so in central city funding the question
the democratic problem expressed in sort
of corporate terms is what do you do to
branch out from investment bankers and
real estate and a huge amount of the
campaign I think can be seen as efforts
by people to sort of pick up a pocket
pocket a business support to add that to
that basic level when you look at what
faux that that cash financing use
discover Frances get part went very
clearly to American industry which is a
rarity for America for a democratic
political candidate and usually the
industrial people end up in the
Republican Party it's pretty clear that
the labor issue there usually keeps them
divided and it worked in the sense that
it got him some initial support I wrote
this up at one point in the nation
briefly and you could find I mean Lee
Iacocca some of the car companies quite
a lot of companies in a fairly sharp
competition with Japan which is an issue
one probably needs to pick up on in
detail in a few minutes but from there
you can see get Park got some real money
from industry you know gore campaigned
heavily on his Pasiphae identified
himself with sort of the Laocoon parties
issues on israel well I was no secret
that David Garth was his campaign
manager and
the kids a media person in a recent
election there now he also did a fair
amount of money from defense contractors
and so forth I mean guy runs on a camp
he's the only Democratic candidate to
sort of contemplate building those two
aircraft carriers now they were under
discussion for example it wants to
complete the sort of build up with a
navy all of that was fairly
straightforward everybody dukakis went
to the high tech people that was the
initial I mean he did a fair amount of
early financing from real estate and
investment banking including a number of
the people who were prominent in the
Mondale effort are very clearly and the
chair the chairmen are senior figures in
a large number of the biggest wall
street houses for Dukakis many in some
cases those people back biden first and
when biden disappeared they went that
was a big help to Dukakis and the caucus
had so much more money than anybody else
all throughout the campaign and I saw
where he spent something like 27 million
compared to Jesse was able to get
something like 12 well yeah I won't
vouch for that figure do what Jackson
started out with almost no money I mean
paradoxically the the more his chances
of election diminished the more money he
got I don't think there's much doubt
that that was he gots he attracted some
money because it looked like he was
actually going to win he attracted some
from various groups in the black
community ranging from I mean there are
now black professionals in corporations
and so forth I mean it's no secret that
I mean the stuff the papers harped on
endlessly but I was 25 or 27
McDonald's franchisees there were black
who gave him some cash and he certainly
got some money because of his position
on the Middle East by people who
disagreed with the the Middle East
positions of Gore somebody yeah
well it's it's often said I don't know
this I haven't seen anybody solidly
researched that but there's hardly any
question that some of the Arab groups in
the United States were out and fairly
close to Jackson I mean it's just you
know these everybody this is the way the
American political system works Jackson
got a third of the vote in the primaries
basically and it is probable that a lot
of people one would have to say enough
to get 10 or 15% votes more probably
agreed with them on most issues except
the middle-east and if you sort of start
adding that and try to define that as
the rock-bottom sort of Liberal
Democratic with a small L majority in
the party you come close to at least
half the party is prepared to sort of
swallow a huge amount of the program
that Jackson took place I mean there are
serious differences on Middle East with
this we know and we don't need any sort
of basic lectures on it but you look at
that and you wonder how you're going to
win an election with let's let's say
half the electorate at least probably is
in it is basically demanding a much more
expansive economic policy more little
bit than Dukakis yeah with a small L
because there's there's no question as I
think the Dukakis campaign has realized
and they've done very well on this is if
you ask people do you like liberalism
only about 20% of the pot with a big L
about 20% of the population will say yes
and the rest will describe themselves as
moderates unless you like the programs
you want to go or you know do you want
to cut the defense budget I mean take
for example the question well all right
let's let me just finish the thought on
Dukakis and then we'll just go sort of
through the electoral both sort of
polling evidence here and sort of where
the party's at I mean the problem is is
that it's conceivable there have been
people in the Democratic Party who have
urged the party to in effect write off
most of the black vote indeed the
liberal vote they don't like them and
they just a lot of them are
conservatives many were no doubt
enthusiastic about Senator Benson
although as I say I don't think Benson's
view of his what he how he conducts
himself in Texas follows that model I
mean in all fairness it's not that
hardline conservative and I haven't been
read out of the Texas Democratic Party
no as far as centrist and wants to
incorporate he understands a political
reality the but you know there certainly
are a lot of people in the Democratic
Party who've essentially urged the party
I mean this makes no sense in terms of
electoral model of politics because the
other party should be able to just leap
frogging go back to that vast 40 or 50
percent of the population you're
ignoring but if you think politics is
driven by cash and then you run in an
electoral system after sort of setting
up your basic sort of cash contributions
fine
natural interests and power block
arrangement then what you get you can be
absolutely sure the Republican Party is
not going to run to your left so you can
effectively if you want to and got some
estimate of how many votes you'll lose
on your left just move to the right and
in effect turn the Democratic Party into
a close to a carbon copy of the
Republicans and essentially compete with
the the four conservative Republican
votes now until a Benson suggests
election I would have said for sure that
was probably not what Dukakis was
planning to do now I have to say I'm not
so sure I still believe that common
sense as well as is on it you know a lot
of people I know know think the guy is
quite reasonable let's pursue this theme
and indicate what the issues of the
election are and starting with your
historical point about the right turn in
which business abandons the Democrats
and goes to the Republicans in the
Reagan years what was the results of the
Reagan years for big business and what
is the position of business now visa vie
the Democrats and Republicans let's go
through a little the history leading up
well elections all right some of the
issues is the emergence well as we say
straightforwardly in right turn I think
common sense will tell you this is that
it's very clear that say in 1981 the
bulk of the American business community
was certainly lined up behind Reagan
this is not news what is interesting and
if you want to understand the world
since then you have to come to grips
with is the fact that Reagan then did
not run you can't treat Reagan as simply
or reaganism as a sort of expression of
sort of the entire business community
and alliance against the rest of the
population you're not going to get
anywhere with that model as we said in
our I turn very quickly when the issue
in the the tax issue was perfect for
this kind of a coalition because it
involves sending money to everybody
especially the people who were rich in
that sense you're not going to find it
break up over that but as soon as they
face the question with the tax the
enormous tax cut opened the way for a
huge budget deficit night and then when
they went to get offsetting expenditures
the business community divided the real
estate people walked out and the
investment bankers and chunks of the
insurance industry began to gang up on
them for letting the deficit grow so
much I mean these
buyers and sellers of long-term bonds
significant parts of the evidence
community move away and then what the
when the administration initially they
let the dollar go way up trying to drive
inflation out of the system and that was
extremely lucrative not for a whole
bunch of people who use the opportunity
especially in manufacturing to get rid
of a lot of workers I mean like the auto
companies got rid of thousands of
workers and you probably couldn't have
done that except in a huge recession no
and so for a while even though the high
interest rate policies were raising the
dollar making it tough to sell abroad
bringing in Japanese goods and crashing
the sort of domestic income that people
will have the bulk of business code is
quite happy with this but then you see
as the income loss gets acute and then
you know their cost reductions won't
carry them all away they start getting
off and there are a lot of unhappy
people in 1983 82 83 walking around even
talking about the Democrats Reagan then
countered with star wars and I think the
thing you really want to keep your eye
on thereafter is the way the American
relationship with Japan developed you
know because what was the sort of the
main line well alright
and Jackson I think this is I must say
an issue that is fundamental and if you
don't understand it you will make no
progress toward understanding what's
happened or what is about to happen
because it this issue isn't going to go
away and it's it's there the question of
what how what's the American posture of
Japan and maybe the easiest way to sort
of get into it in a couple minutes is to
sort of go through start from the stuff
that's all around now about is the
American Empire collapsing and are we
overextended the sort of Paul Kennedy
book in particular in Paul Kennedy's
historical study the decline of empires
is a great deal of writing about is the
American Empire past its peak and are we
being succeeded by Japan well if you
want to understand what the American
business community's response to this is
you understand is that many of them are
not embarrassed by the Imperial
comparison but they think of it exactly
the opposite way a very nice
illustration of this implicitly isn't as
a big new Brzezinski essay and foreign
affairs not long ago in their position
is is if the American Empire wants to
hold together
problem is not over extension is it is
that it must have a position in the new
fast-growing area in the world
which is the Pacific and for that they
think their relationship with Japan is
utterly fundamentally as Brzezinski said
in this piece there you can't imagine
how you could develop the Pacific except
in partnership with Japan in that sense
a happy relationship between the sort of
American multinational firms that want
to go into the Pacific and Japan is
fundamental on the other hand Japan is
killing a good chunk of American
industry I mean what with completely
legal competition are well we can
discuss the economic interest in the US
and well keep Japan the distance and to
one well the question is incredibly
complicated and you're not going to get
anywhere with a simple approach which
says well it's the US versus Japan what
you got to understand is first of all
many American multinationals respond to
this question by simply transferring
production abroad as Jackson said in
this campaign then they go they go to
Taiwan or to the other parts of Asia now
that gives them a big stake in Southeast
days you're not gonna you're not going
anywhere with a program in the American
business community it says let's retract
from Southeast Asia on the other hand
what these people then do is start
exporting to the rest of the world and
indeed back in the United States indeed
as you there's some very nice studies
even coming out of the National Bureau
of Economic Research which essentially
say that well if you look at sort of the
way the US export position is declined
in the world you'll see a fairly
significant decline although a good deal
of its concentrated saying earlier than
one would have thought but then when you
look at sort of incorporate sort of
exports from Southeast Asia and other
countries where US firms are there
there's been no decline in US exports as
if you count those firms over there it's
entirely the domestic issue now in many
cases some of those firms even export in
Japan indeed you can see the Japanese
sometimes when they've now recently
tried to as the Reagan administration's
had to put more pressure on them they
sometimes respond by buying more goods
from Southeast Asia a policy which you
can't understand let you understand in
many cases that the American firms that
are pushing the government that are
getting their exports bought there that
does them good it doesn't do the rest of
the population much good anyway that's
one strand of the relationship on the
other so you ask yourself well then
who's the natural
opponents of this policy you can see
there how from the standpoint of the
general population in effect they're
asked to sort of pay the fabulous
military and foreign policy cost that's
over extension such as tax dollars that
underwrites the military power the
foreign aid the sort of money for
intelligence operations and so forth
this is big what you might call the
Imperial overhead it's very costly now
the beneficiaries of that are largely
American multinationals who in many
cases are exporting jobs out of the
United States all right that's just
fairly that's just perfectly clear on
the other so you might ask yourself why
would any multinational or indeed any
large firm then not find this that's
very attractive when all the criticism
of Japan well the short answer is is
that while a fair number of people just
go overseas some people can't the
high-tech industry is one that while it
moves a lot of assembly overseas does a
lot of product development things over
here and or in many cases it's small
farms for whatever they can't move or
they can't move all their production
easily fast enough what the Reagan
people had to live with this - after all
the Republicans are traditionally the
party of industry the party of business
and they've got to have a Japan policy
what they did is they started out they
they preached free trade and they then
tried to make accommodation with like
the most powerful sectors like auto and
steel got import quotas that very
quickly turned out not to be enough and
so what they did for a while was protest
with the Japanese and try to get him
dope they would try a sort of dual
policy of trying to get him to open
their markets and sort then I came up
with Star Wars that was the other half
of the dual policy just looking at it as
a scheme to funnel cash to high
technology industries it was an
interesting response and it's not I
think an accident that it was announced
a few months after the Democrats
Industrial Policy program but then what
the 84 eleven that got them through the
84 election the combination of general
Recovery Star Wars and so forth and then
of course the Democrats on and basilic
all we will do for you is raise your
taxes well we want to come back because
Mike Dukakis is possibly in the position
of now telling you
maybe all he'll do for you is raise
taxes and negotiate creeping Mondale as
well now he hasn't said that yet he has
he said you know the question is not a
tax rise it's clear when you look at
like the last ball Gallup polls which I
thought were the most
ways to ask the question does the
population want the budget balanced yes
how do they want it balanced it's clear
that as the majority of the population
wants or at least of those with opinions
want it balanced by cutting military
spending and they basically would like
to spend more on social spending and I
mean this is this is what we said in the
first chapter right turn and it's it's
not news even this morning's New York
Times or yesterday's makes the point
again a survey that yeah does seem the
population is rather more to the left of
the government they don't quite put it
like that but that's what they're saying
but now let me that's creeping creeping
Mondale ISM is saying all you're going
to do people is raise taxes you could do
the tax issue if you're going to give
them something for what you can't do is
tell them we're going to raise taxes so
we can spend more money abroad to aid
American multinationals that you cannot
do and expect to win an election and
that I think is I mean I don't think
this is in the it's settled that's why I
think that one wants to watch very
carefully how the dukakis people
approach the Jackson people because the
question of and they say they want to
hold the line on defense spending but
they don't want to cut it what are they
planning to do for the population I
don't think it's probably going to be
enough to say we promise you somehow
that we will get you good jobs at good
wages if you're going to pull them out
of a hat but let me come back to the
Japanese question okay what the Reagan
administration did since 84 is
essentially it began to spend more and
more money in direct subsidies not so
not through Star Wars but through other
programs like the supercollider product
of the semiconductor program SEMATECH
that they set up here in Austin is an
example of that they have an effect
channel more and more money to I mean
they've met the the sort of Japanese
problem by in effect without saying so
they have built up they begun to build
up the Defense Department not so much
through Star Wars which is a separately
designated program as an effect in
American media they're doing rather more
industrial targeting now than they admit
they're trying to respond to the
Japanese by a good deal more targeting
and I think with the wholly salutary
claim usually they will usually the
Democrats on this will usually say we
should also like to shift there is a
critique of the uses of military
surely military focus in this spending a
lot of people think they could do better
with more civilian spending emphasis on
my products that somebody wants to buy
is Jackson said so nicely during the
campaign you know how many of you you
know own a VCR some lots of people raise
their hand how many of you own an MX
missile nobody wants to buy that well
that's of course one thing the election
is about but so the Japan question is
the Democrats definitely embody I'd say
a joint business labor response now the
labor response here is quite it's
probably worth pursuing this I mean the
Jackson himself said very powerfully and
I think it's very important that the
point get made again and again the one
major way the us sort of has lost out an
international economic competition is
that sort of the American defense budget
and foreign aid policies go to regimes
in the third world that essentially wipe
out independent trade unions right and
in effect they hold workers wages down
and they use the resources of the United
States and often the to do it to put it
simply and bluntly indeed I think you
could you can generalize this point
which is is that a huge amount of the
American tax problem the fiscal problem
is about how are you going to divide the
costs of empire in the population and
the plain facts are is that we spend a
huge amount of our money and time
supporting regimes in the third world
that basically make it attractive for
businesses from here to move and
uh Jackson I think did everybody service
and raising that issue even as much as
for instance the New York Times quoted
unnamed people and one or two people who
claim to be Democrats ridiculing the
whole approach to that there's nothing
crazy about the view I think and is
certainly no there's no economic logic
in saying that a regime that sort of in
effect murders trade unionists who are
sort of trying to form reasonable trade
unions should not get the support of the
United States I think it's a really
important questions that one thing you
can do to sort of restructure the United
States economy is stop subsidizing this
indirect form of subsidy and
out abroad as the one short term of us
not so much indirect their tax breaks
for the companies overseas American
company overseas and so it's grants I'm
here yeah I may add that another aspect
I think of Jackson's campaign that it
was extremely interesting is the way
that point was developed the Jackson
campaign just says look you've got if
you stop holding down workers wages
abroad and indeed join in general
efforts to sort of reflect the rest of
the world you can develop the United
States and not at the expense of the
rest of the world and that this is
unfortunately Jackson's position which
is a minority one here what's the
difference exactly between the Democrats
and Republicans essentially what the
bush people are talking is I mean they
are doing more industrial targeting
under the guise of defense spending but
apart from that they're continuing to
talk what I think is fairly traditional
free trade trying to pressure the
Japanese and to sort of do more military
spending to spend more of their trade
surpluses on foreign aid and they're
eventually we're also looking for the
third world bank bailout they are
certainly got their eyes fixed I think
first on the Pacific the dukakis people
on the other hand
partly because of those two know the
plain solid trade question which you
can't get around from in which storms it
forms the perfect flying buttress
between a chunk of American industry and
a chunk of the American labor movement
the afl-cio which would love to block
out Japanese goods the or most of the
most the unions would they do seem to be
rather less interested in Japan parsley
for that and spending somewhat more
interested in NATO and European concerns
they are well aware I think of a fact
which is I think shortly to destabilize
American politics again in which in my
opinion will help shape it's sort of
long-run fundamental problems a great
deal which I think probably in a way
that squeezes the domestic population
which is very simply this is by 1992 the
european economic community has to merge
its its financial rules and they're
going to have open capital mobility and
in general one mark at least that's
their aim yeah and they're likely to do
that they're in effect while that's not
a United States of Europe it's a major
step toward it now that as they do that
that's going to stimulate tremendous
economic competition for a lot of people
who've never had it well you can see
when foreign friends have been coming
into the US you can all argue about
whether that's good or bad but the plain
fact is a lot of people don't like it
and you know even in this country which
has you know is basically an enormously
open market in financial terms there's a
lot of pressure to close it the same
thing is true in Europe why won't your
Appiah new pians close it the answer is
because the US will do them services
like pay for their defense for example I
mean again the military and foreign aid
budget is going to be used to subsidize
American firms doing business in Europe
now that's the question is who's going
to pay for that they are mostly not
going to be charged for that in the
sense of what the Reagan tax programs
meant is that you're going to throw more
and more the tax burden
the net effect that is certainly to
throw the tax burden on the poor and the
middle classes now then what's going to
happen cuz in effect I mean that this
right now the line among all the US
business groups is we have to reach
wrench we must make the allies pay more
the the what's going to happen when they
don't or when they move they will do
something obviously but then the US has
to keep paying the deficit grows and so
tax pressures well the key to this seems
to me is that in fact they are paying
for our for our military because it's
the Europeans and the Japanese who by
and large are buying
holding the American debt well that's
that's correct that you got a problem
here and that it's hard to think of any
earthly reason given the sort of present
condition of the Soviet Union why
anybody in Europe is really going to
want to pay more for Defence I mean the
it's surely the case their chances of
being invaded in Europe have never been
less than the post-war period than they
are now it's very hard for me to imagine
how the population in America can be
persuaded to sort of go to inferior
schools sort of have a worse social
welfare system generally have sort of
more poor in meager lives in order to
sort of build up sort of the American
contribution to European defenses
without the threat of sort of world
communism I think how the parties play
Gorbachev is very important and there
now let me just swing to the question
you ask how's Bush playing this well we
know what the Reagan administration did
I think initially motivated in part by
the sheer fact that once Gorbachev said
he wants to deal the West Germans work
very clearly willing to deal and we're
going to deal whether the United States
did it or not
now Bush in one of my things that came
to light of my campaign finance study is
that in many parts of the defense
industry are anxious as can be about the
top there was a powerful anti d'etat
bloc and it's interesting to see that
Bush in his campaign has moved very much
against the Reagan policy in the last
couple of months in other words after
dole folded he sort of took over some of
the issue there and the question is what
will Dukakis do and I think you will get
air I mean at the moment he's sort of
saying well some people are telling me
the Gorbachev is sincere I saw him I saw
I've said that the other day on the
other hand the main lines coming out of
his advisors are it would be folly to
negotiate rapidly with the Soviet Union
and it's true you could make a stupid
deal that would there any number of ways
these things can miscarry but the truth
of the matter is is that they could make
an agreement fairly rapidly if they
wanted to now the question is do they
want to the trouble is if you do that I
don't know how you persuade the
population to sort of spend on a cash on
on overseas military
Varian foreign aid the sort of whole
question the American Empire I really
think there is a fundamental issue here
is that you have got to have a large
chunk of the population just sit there
and believe that they are going to be
swept away by the red tide at the first
sign of any sort of you know if the Navy
dropped to say 500 ships instead of 559
listen this was something that was that
was brought home as I've read about
Truman that he was saying that they were
going to have these big commitments to
Europe and all unless there is no way to
do that is you're going to have to scare
the hell out of the American people and
they decide to scare the hell out of the
American people to justify all this
expense with the red I don't think there
is any question a number of people in
the Truman administration now that the
documents have recently come out on some
of the things on the background papers
to the NSC 68 and some of the other sort
of major foreign policy pronouncements
there we're perfectly well trying to
crank up the domestic politics of the
United States by using international
arguments international foreign policy
arguments do I think that's exactly
right
the question I have for the election is
what will the position of say Bush and
Dukakis be visa vie Gorbachev in the
Soviet Union
obviously the Reagan administration did
the biggest defense buildup in history
the defense industries have been
absolutely not percentage Charles yeah
being behind Reagan Bush the Republicans
100 percent Bush is also indicate he's
going to keep a high level of defense
spending well alright well there's a
sector of industry retreat policy that's
going to be sharply Republican now
Dukakis on the other hand is saying he
wants to cut back on defense spending
it's not what he's saying well look
again what he's actually saying is he
wants to sort it he does not want to
chop it any further and he wants to hold
the defense spending roughly constant
now this is kind of interesting to
follow it's clear that if you abstract
from what the Reagan administration is
saying I mean Bush now but the Reagan
administration the policy that Carlucci
is actually following on military
spending which is a sort of try to hold
it steady is very close to what Dukakis
is talking I have to add to that I think
the budget pressures in the next
administration would make a difficult
all even Forbush to increase military
spending I think you're looking at both
parties I think maybe converging on not
something the population wants the
population clearly wants the budget cut
the defense budget cut I think that is
just you I don't know how you can escape
that conclusion you look at for instance
the Gallup polls and so forth even when
you give them choices you know but they
want to hold it even and then the
interesting question is where do you go
to get new money for programs thank the
Republicans won't do many new programs
the Democrats have a bigger problem now
this brings us to the tax question in to
the sort of heart of some of the
interesting economics of the Dukakis
administration I I don't think they've
shown their hand they're open on this
question in a sense the future is open
much of it is couched in the discussion
of we have to get the savings rate ox
now let's just talk about that for a
minute because this is the fraud in your
future the savings rate question the see
the one starts out with you know scare
figures usually pit the US personal rate
of saving not that sort of total rate
which include corporate savings and
pettite but the personal rate against
the sort of full Japanese figure and
then your our urge to believe that
there's some ironclad link between sort
of economic growth and tolls saving
because that's linked to total
investment and then what they'd like to
do is have you buy less and export more
and get and cut government spending a
substantial amount less - yeah we import
less and export more I'm sorry maybe I
didn't make that yes the net balanced
export more and it's it's simply deficit
reduction it is not different basically
from what Mondale was talking about and
the interesting question is whether
they'll go ahead with it there's a lot
of people there are some people around
Dukakis that are cautioning them about
this just telling you no why would
anyone vote for this and what's going to
happen when you do it I don't know the
the the United States does not need
another bout of austerity if the
Democrats bring another bout of
austerity I think the key point to sort
of understand here is that you're not
going to have to worry about the memory
of Franklin Roosevelt you're going to
have to worry about the specter of
Grover Cleveland the guy who wrecked the
Democratic Party for a generation with
his response to a populist movement in
1894 what about
to the Republicans Bush talked about
voodoo economics you know Bush is going
to do exactly the sink was I think but
Bush is saying the same thing you say
look we got these big deficits we got to
get them down we got to keep military
spending up and we don't want to raise
taxes he would like to the deficit Eli
Bush would like to chop social spending
a good deal more I think I think much
already they're all one they talk about
you look at what they say it's that the
Republican line repeated by by us can
repeat it by Bush's we got to get at
entitlements read Social Security not
that much to chop away well it seems
that Reagan went about as far as he
could not true shot look you're still
getting my mother is still getting her
Social Security check that set could
either be eliminate or reduce
politicians have seen that that's
something that can't be tampered with
that was a lesson Reagan learned early I
hope you're right but when George Bush
says he'll never never never raise your
tax that means Annie wants to cut the
deficit what does he mean by that
Tom we've talked a lot about the big
issues in the election some of the
historical background the economic
forces the different candidates and
their programs what does this leave us
now as we look at the future of American
politics what would be a better road say
for the Democratic Party to take as they
move into the election and then into the
next regime well let's question about a
better road let's just take it for
almost from a clinical standpoint for a
minute which will then very quickly lead
to a consideration of what they are what
in some sense would be better policy for
the vast majority of us this is think
the really key question here is how the
Jackson movement fits into the
Democratic Party okay and here you have
to sort of deal with a number of facts
first it is it is plainly true that the
sort of left or liberal sort of voting
population the Democratic Party is
larger than the Jackson in that sense
the Jackson is a lower bound estimate of
that because there are very clearly
people who don't agree with them on
other issues especially the middle east
one which certainly created a lot of
turmoil in the campaign in that sense
you're actually looking at a substantial
may I think it's clearly the case that
candidates in the future who want to
take a flyer in the party in the
National Campaign Ron
including maybe Jax himself again could
conceivably win so let's focus in on the
Jackson Carradine and the Jackson
phenomenon with impact okay and in us
it's worth thinking about this a fair
amount because one line was I mean the
one thing you have to settle up in your
mind is did is it true that he had no
media support and did he do this all
without the media or not they're busy
without money
yeah and they're basically two lines
here the Jackson people complain I think
with a good deal of justice somebody has
shown for example a nice comparison that
Reagan had plenty of openly racist
comments in his past record that you
could show on TV they didn't cut to
those in 1980 when he was running for
president although people were always
cutting back to the Farrakhan remarks in
the Jackson Canada [ __ ] town New York
yep that that's one on the other hand
it's also true I think and there are
some evidence to suggest that Jackson
got a lot of sort of favorable comment
there's one little Institute in
Washington that claims he got quite
favorable treatment now it turns out
when you look at what they mean by
favorable treatment they mean simply
somebody saying anything good about him
at all and then they admit in the next
breath that well there were no issues
discuss well how do you discuss Jesse
Jackson without issues well you know
there I think there was some suggestion
well he's black it would be nice to have
a black run for president for a while
plus it was a sensitive issue and he may
have benefited for a while there's no
question that when Jackson got close
after he destroyed Dukakis in Michigan
you know that the media turned on a man
he was certainly vicious and it was one
of the worst example most outrageously
unfair press campaigns anybody will ever
see now this brings in the liberal media
to like NPR and all those people and
they were all I didn't almost without
almost without exception now this brings
us to a really important point part of
that campaign was a Washington post/abc
poll which came out a story in the post
then was widely ventilated which claimed
that Jackson had not brought in any new
voters now when I read that and that
became quickly the official line I was
at Amazon watched a couple weeks ago I
was Brittany do when was this when was
this
oh I escaped Smee now you'll have to
check back exactly what day that story
came out when this came out I said to
myself there's something wrong so I
called up first the post and then ABC
where I would have to say we're two of
the rudest conversations I've ever had
they were extremely upset and would not
more the point I asked them I said look
you know I would like to check this
could I see I had a hunch as to what was
wrong at that point I said could I see
your Pole no I couldn't see the pole now
that's pretty outrageous Lang is just a
scandal when a major Network and a major
newspaper will not release to reasonably
qualified people their poll and you
can't do things like that and a sort of
reasonably honest system at any rate
well I then very la Times people very
kindly made available to me a poll and
then after I looked at that for a while
it was pretty easy to see what was going
on which is this is that we know we've
been some several excellent validation
studies it turns out when you ask people
did you vote in the last election they
are often about 25% of them will often
say they did when in fact they didn't
now what the able will you read the
story of the post you know since I don't
know exactly what they did since I
wouldn't talk tell me I don't feel but
it's clear they didn't make that
correction instead what they did is they
tried to estimate the percentage of
people who really voted just using their
self-reported voting but that was too
high in other words a lot of those
people who said they vote all that they
didn't vote that's right a lot of those
people who said they voted did not and
then of course that's that there you go
now when you try to find a direct
measure of what did Jackson actually do
there is a question that is a very good
one on the LA Times poll and there of
the people who said they didn't vote you
know which is that too has report
problems but if they're willing to say
they didn't by much more likely they
didn't of those people who said they
didn't vote in the New York primary
where the turnout was incidentally
enormous much higher than it
the than 8480 the r84 I didn't check the
80 figures but I'm sure and any right
there something like 64 percent was
people who said they didn't vote said
they voted for Jackson I don't think
there's any
question that as long as it seemed this
guy had a reasonable chance to win at
all and indeed even before that in the
sense that Wisconsin had a relatively
high turnout and so the some southern
states did others had normal turnouts
and then people are fighting as to
whether it was the Democrats or
Republicans who turned out it's very
clear Jackson did probably bring in new
voters claims by them you know the major
media ABC Washington Post stuff that he
didn't his III don't like there's any
warrant for that all it's very clear
that the whole question of voter
registration the Democratic Party has so
far largely walked away from it no and
you know I think if the Dukakis
administration is serious about being an
inclusive administration I think you
should watch very closely their response
to that see the original Democrats do
not want a big voter registration
turnout because that means the more
radical candidates the more left
candidates at least I think there's no
doubt well are exactly that that is
precisely what worries them well you
made that point in right turn on our
program previously that the rich people
whose part there the Democrats are much
better served if a conservative if the
they would say they would lose by
winning if they won with a with a fully
mobilized electro yeah I'd much rather
have that yeah
the conservative Democrats much rather
have Reagan and then they led there on
the other hand we know and Michael
Dukakis knows and all the big Democratic
leaders know that Jackson did bring in a
lot of people I'm I took people for the
election if they want to win so that
means there's got to be some
accommodation by the Democrat okay and
there's been certainly big incentives on
the particular with the Supreme Court uh
you got the Supreme Court appointments
to be made and you go judiciary that is
it almost destroyed in a rares with all
these right-wing it's you I think that
and the the Republican administrations
recent moves on civil rights have been
just outrageous I mean in terms of
trying to roll back some of the legal
protections there so in that sense
handle I wouldn't suggest he should take
a walk I do think though that people it
would be helpful to think I do believe
it if if the if as I hope he doesn't the
Dukakis administration too
a conservative course is I but if he
does it then I would expect a of real
brittle administration and I think
you'll probably find that the first time
they get a shock they'll find themselves
without much public support and so you'd
have to look for sort of a mid-course
correction or midterm sort of reassembly
the coalition which might get a bit of
something of a New Deal coalition which
would include the Jackson forces as his
support and then he would have to give
them social programs cut back on
military spending have a policy that
incorporates traditional New Deal issues
yeah and it's not clear Dukakis wants to
do this so it's going to be very
interesting yeah like I said the shorty
the Democrats in 1988 is between
Roosevelt and Grover Cleveland